new tent city is opened on the greek
island of lesbos this facility is meant
to
house migrants left homeless after fire
destroyed the notorious
moria refugee camp but most of those
displayed say conditions on lesbos are
so unbearable that they want to leave
for mainland europe
greece's prime minister is calling on
other european union countries
to help out and take in more migrants
new arrivals settle into life in the
replacement migrant camp on lesbos
while the facility is still being built
greek authorities remain
hopeful all will be re-housed within the
week
since the notoriously overcrowded moria
camp burned down
most migrants have been forced to sleep
on the streets
iraqi refugee and photographer yusuf
ashwali
is angry at just how desperate
conditions have become
look at the people sleeping
in the gas stations on the streets and
the roads
no masks no medical care
here is the children
[Music]
look at the children
look at the children
some migrants have even chosen to stay
at the scorched moria camp
locals say they too are angry at the
situation
we are approaching disaster there is no
growth
we should have tourism but we have had
nothing for five years now we are living
in a constant state of fear
five hundred migrants became one
thousand and two thousand
and we are still in the same situation
this is a disgrace the authorities
fooled us
they must leave as soon as possible we
treated them well when they first came
but they destroyed our island the greek
government is also to blame
most migrants on lesbos just want to
leave the island
but they fear the new camp means that
won't be happening
anytime soon